Ron DeSantis knows who he wants to face
in the general election and it's not Joe
Biden the Florida governor hitting back
after a Relentless mudslinging attacks
from Gavin Newsom the pair have been
duking it out over hot button issues
including migrant flights and Newsome's
pathetic threat to throw him in jail the
scientists thinks it's time for Gavin to
man up and get into the race for the
White House
you know what stop pussy-footing around
are you gonna
are you gonna throw your hat in the ring
and challenge uh Joe are you going to
get in and do it or are you just going
to sit on the sidelines and Chirp so why
don't you throw your hat in the ring and
then we'll go ahead and talk about what
what's happening
but I guess Gavin likes being on the
sidelines here he is repeatedly ruling
out a White House run
are you considering running for
president in 2024 or 2028 not even
considering not at all it's not my
ambition it's not the direction that I'm
leaning into how many times is your
phone ping a day people saying you need
to get in this race I see where you're
going with that I'm asking no I and I'm
not answering
but that doesn't mean Newsom wouldn't
relish the chance to debate his
ideological foe
you would do a two-hour debate with
Rhonda said I would make it three three
hour debate yeah
do it with one day notice with no notes
I look forward to that
okay Martha what is the motivation for
yeah
between Gavin Newsom and Rhonda Sanders
you know is this very interesting I mean
I love how he I always listen to you
know politicians words very closely
right it's like it's not my ambition
it's not the way I'm leaning right now
in other words that could change at any
moment right if Joe Biden decides not to
run I think a lot of people wonder if
Joe Biden might do a Lyndon Johnson you
know might sort of at some point say
I've decided I'm not going to actually
run again he does that the signs are not
in that direction right now but I think
there's every reason to think that
that's a possibility that that could
happen I think in some ways this is good
for Rhonda Santos because it draws him
out I talk to a lot of people who say
where is he interesting you know they
want to know why he's not out there more
why he's not doing more interviews I
know he spent time in Iowa New Hampshire
and he's doing that work which is really
important to do but I I think a lot of
folks you know like to see him drawn out
and and that the Donald Trump issues
have kind of suck the oxygen out of the
room which is happens all the time right
but he needs to find his way to get in
and and to make his Mark so this kind of
provided him a little bit of an opening
um to to get in the conversation
you know Greg what do you think would be
more interesting a three-hour debate
between DeSantis and Newsome or watching
that
or Joe Biden going uh into a debate with
Donald Trump well this is a good
question because this is like a boxing
bill right you have the lower card it's
called the undercard undercard
fan you're in gutfels yeah
all right
you know it's like the undercard so
they're going to edit out that first
part yeah yeah they are because this is
a tape show uh you got Gavin the
nuisance uh Newsome versus uh raw the
dissenter DeSantis but it's really about
the top card
which is Joe Versus the Volcano although
Ron is at least being honest about it
he's thrown his hair in the ring but
Gavin is pretending that he's not
running for president when we know he is
you know he's all glory no hold we like
to say uh but I think that Gavin is
defective in that he's managing to run
for president happy Friday yes yeah he's
managed to run for president without
declaring he's running for president
he's definitely not governing California
none of this stuff has to do with
California who's running California it's
just like Joe with America United States
who's running it it's really strange I
don't think Democrats actually run
anything they're in charge of but it's
clear that he's on a PR crusade to erase
any flaws or obstacles that are going to
show up next year and around February
2024 you're probably going to see when
Joe drops out you'll see Gavin step in
with the my pillow and then he'll uh
okay thanks you're welcome all right
uh what do you think you think that Joe
is going to drop out I mean and by the
way you know what I think I think
Gutfeld needs a drink yeah and ribs but
you know what Gavin newsom's wife came
out and talked about something that
happened between something very tragic
between her and her sister and her
sister ended up dying and it's a very
sad situation but it's almost like let's
get this all out because we're getting
ready to run here's what's happening Joe
Biden and this and Gavin Newsom cut a
deal and the deal is Gavin's not going
to primary Joe Biden and they're gonna
make
Gavin Newsom The Heir Apparent Gavin
Newsom just has to attack DeSantis
doesn't matter about attacking Trump
Biden's got that covered he's arresting
him they just need to run up to Santa's
negatives right now and it never looked
good when Joe Biden was attacking
DeSantis remember he did it for about
two years and it Joe is really old
looking and DeSantis was young and
confident in Florida and it kind of
backfired so they're like let's send a
younger more liberal guy out there to
attack DeSantis and let's attack him on
issues that Joe can't handle immigration
and trans that seems to be the issue
because when you're attacking DeSantis
DeSantis is then attacking
Newsom and he's not attacking Joe Biden
so he's kind of drawing desantis's
attacks away from Joe Biden
footing around is a great line and I'm
glad he used it and he used it in a
humorous and Casual way he said this
guy's obsessed with me he's obsessed
everyone's leaving his State and he just
dismissed them but these two are on a
collision course whether it's in two
years or six years you got a big
governor and a big state they're young
they've got nice looking families
they're both energetic they're both very
combative and sooner or later they're
going to rip each other's faces off well
you know given what's going on right now
Richard with uh Comer and the house and
the Republicans and we heard about that
you know that unclassified 1023 and now
there's allegedly tapes in addition to
all the money that's flowing into the
Biden family you think there's a chance
that Biden will step down and this is
part of a bigger plan no I don't think
so at all and I mean we're not really
sure I mean in an interview he said he
wasn't sure if the tips were legit or
not but on this DeSantis issue I think
he has to listen to them I I I I I don't
know I don't know what comes I don't
know what Cove is doing I mean if he if
he had it he would have had a hearing
about it but I digress well no he
couldn't get it from Chris like I said
if he had if they had the evidence they
would have had a hearing but let's focus
on this one wait a minute no he just got
it from Christopher Ray all he does is
do television interviews and he hasn't
had a hearing yet but anyway back to
Gavin Newsom and Ron DeSantis because I
think that's a very interesting story
Jesse I'm not sure if you're watching
the same television show because last
time I checked the person dumping on Ron
DeSantis is Donald Trump right every day
he's attacking Ron DeSantis and it seems
to be working because like tomorrow at
this point nobody knows what Rhonda
Sanchez is and I think in this clip that
we saw here Ronda Santos was signing the
state's budget and what you find out in
this state budget is that he's in in
fighting with Donald Trump once again in
the budget he vetoed a 20 million dollar
investment for the for the uni for the
University of South Florida's Nursing
campus during a nursing shortage because
the Senators whose District that's in
haste endorse Donald Trump he also
vetoed 3.6 million dollars for opioid
treatment he vetoed 17 drainage
Improvement projects all in the same
budget he wants to make this fight about
between him and Gavin Newsom but it
seems very clear talking about not being
able to manage somebody's state it seems
that Ron DeSantis seems more trying to
win this primary more than I'm actually
trying to govern the State of Florida
why is everybody moving to Florida I'm
talking about the polls I mean clearly
he's like he's not talking about people
moving with their feet not the pulse
yeah listen you can have this
conversation if you want to he's she's
running for now he's a candidate and I
will sure right now he's running for
president of the United States and he is
losing to Donald Trump by what 20 points
in the last poll even worse right and I
I always feel like judge to be honest
with you spend so much time talking
about drag queens maybe he wants to be
one and who Ron DeSantis oh she spent so
much time talking about drag queens and
what they shouldn't do and where they
shouldn't perform and where they should
be and where they shouldn't be it's just
you know maybe he wants to put away
if somebody introduces an idea that you
debate they go oh well maybe why are you
so obsessed with him
pedophiles my whole life
that's completely different why I was
obsessed with that because I hated what
they did listen I think a drag queen and
a pedophile are two completely different
things I will agree on that absolutely
but I think
who said what hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else